oui alors la semaine dernière qu est ce
qui s'est passé je me souviens de rien
merci c'est incroyable je dois de la
vodka à dire que ici on vous sert
énormément de vodka tonic et une fille
très charmant très jolie chapelle nd
rica voilà qui laisse aller très bien
passé son temps à venir me voir est ce
que vous voulez encore un verre je
disais oui et c'est tout ça se passait à
une manière sympathique jusqu'au moment
où je me suis dit que j'étais trop
éméchés pour parler d'un livre qui est
important pour moi
back est important c'est que c'est un
livre c'est grave et voilà mais mais
c'est bien dans la rue effectivement là
tous les gens pendant une semaine m'ont
demandé comment j'allais si je
connaissais l'aspect gic milwaukee bucks
dit
donc c'est très finalement c'est une
belle aventure
votre maman vous l'avais dit je fais je
faire dix ont regardé quand elle vous a
vu tomber dans la loge
ouais ouais c'est ben oui non je devrais
dire aux gens qui nous regardent ne
faites pas ça chez vous c'est mal il
faut pas comment ça va très bien vous
connaissez oui oui oui bien présente
comme un merci d'être venu comme ça au
débotté au débotté marque et loire merci
beaucoup embrasé au malawi mais bon
support points à brûle pourpoint oui
j'ai tous les mois alors quand big baby
nous sommes tous américains vous vous
dites nous sommes tous irakien ah oui
bien sûr allez frédéric tu peux tu peux
me dire à moi c'est ça c'est un gag ton
livre tu peux pas sérieusement avoir
fait ça enfin sincèrement en six mois
pour moi le la seule excuse ce serait le
stream le stylisme si tu veux si tu
étais cynique et que tu que tu ai fait
ça dans une volonté de publicité
d'ailleurs très très louable pour faire
quelque chose pendant le 11 septembre
je comprendrais mais là plusieurs fois
je t'écoute et tu as tu as une 1ère de
gravité tu as l'air de vraiment de 2,2
de croire en ce que tu dis et je trouve
ça grave mais pourquoi part parce que la
situation n'est pas halal à la
plaisanterie avec ce genre de sujet
c'est fait vous lui reprocher d'être oui
loin le pays le fille c'est par cette
gravité là si on ne peut pas tu peux pas
mais l'état superficialité aux gravats
du wall trade center tu vois et je te le
dis parce que il ya beaucoup de copains
et moi je ne suis pas un copain je suis
un ami et un ami c'est quelqu'un qui
doit te dire la vérité enfin en tout cas
sa vérité et je mange pas je ne fais pas
partie de ces types qui te tresse des
louanges et des loges par intérêt ou par
complaisance ou ou pour différents
métiers moi j'aime beaucoup le livre de
frédéric mans bien sûr mais il ya
quelque chose qui m'a kiki dont on ne
peut absolument pas
enfin qu'on peut pas passer sous silence
c'est cette apologie de l'amérique que
tu fais aujourd'hui elle est extrêmement
déplacé deux ans après à après ce qui
s'est passé le 11 septembre 2001 il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup d'événements qui se
sont produits depuis deux ans étienne tu
n'as pas l'air d'en tenir compte en fait
ce que tu dis c'est que nous sommes tous
américains c'est ce qui se disait tout
de suite après on peut avoir de la
compassion pour les victimes
pleurer c'est ce qu'on fait en ce moment
essayé de tenir compte un peu de ce qui
s'est passé dans la tête de ces gens qui
se sont retrouvés prisonniers dans dans
les deux tours mais depuis cet événement
il s'est passé deux guerres les
américains se sont comportés comme des
deux véritables fumier on peut le dire
cesser c'est indéfendable
on ne peut défendre qu'une idée de
l'amérique mais une idée ou vieillotte
qui qui appartient à des à des vieux
ringards qui voit l'amérique comme à
l'époque du western tu vois ou alors
comme des golden boys des années 80 mais
l'amérique aujourd'hui n'est plus celle
d'avant le 11 septembre
ça ne dérange pas que je réponde à un
moment on a effectivement moi je suis
aussi ton amie et quand tu as publié un
livre après le 11 septembre intitulé une
lueur d'espoir j'ai été choqué j'étais
choquée j'ai trouvé ça avec la
couverture publicitaire elle aussi avec
les le cloud 0 avec marc et une lueur
d'espoir je trouve que voilà je peux
être ami avec toi et n'être d'accord sur
rien ça ne me dérange pas je peux quand
même boire un verre avec toi si tu veux
c'est que nous en parlons mais au delà
de 2 des excuse moi tu te répète un peu
moins longuement que toi mais quand même
un petit peu je trouve d'abord je n'ai
jamais dit que nous étions tous
américains c'est jean marie colombani
moi j'ai pas écrit ça et il ya aucun
moment écrit ça mais en revanche c'est
vrai qu'on peut avoir de la compassion
on peut aussi considérer que l'amérique
ne fait pas que des erreurs y compris
depuis le 11 septembre et en en espérant
on n'ira ni n'at-elle pas fait si tu
veux mais par exemple par exemple virer
saddam hussein et essayer d'inverser
démocratie et sa mémoire
aucune démocratie possible en irak de
toute façon pour un très très longtemps
et c'est ils n'ont pas voulu virer
saddam hussein pour imposer la
démocratie il ya une puérile it et si tu
veux et je trouve que tu que tu devrais
te réveiller au monde
moi je pense que ces marchés et c'est
extrêmement ringard aujourd'hui de
défendre des fans de lecture c'est la
démocratie et sert à rien c'est pas la
démocratie ni la liberté l'amérique
facettes c'est tellement évident
aujourd'hui moins que jamais pardonné
millions et des millions d'arabes ac et
loire qui qui qui qui souffrent de 7 de
celle des sentiments de la mort quand il
disait moins pire et compliqué je suis
concerné le réseautage est dire si on
pouvait virer tous les dictateurs je
serai bien mais on ne peut pas virer des
dictateurs au choix de celui qui est le
plus facile à virer exactement dire que
moi je pense que par exemple que j'ai
beaucoup plus dangereux la situation en
corée du nord tout le monde le sait et
au pakistan surtout parce que le
pakistan et y aura un coup d'état ça
c'est sûr et c'est les islamistes qui
vont prendre le pouvoir ils vont enlever
musharraf et là ils auront les bons
bateaux normes et la première chose
qu'ils vont faire céder donnaient
d'évidents son bouquin qui a tué daniel
pearl je vais avec répondait à mark
edwards qui moi je considère que
l'amérique c'est effectivement la
liberté la démocratie que ils nous ont
libérés des nazis en 44 que nous on les
a libérés aussi des anglais bien avant
tu ne paies fierté des liens entre nous
non la mairie serait faut seulement des
types qui sont venus nous libérer des
nazis c'est ça il faut avancer avec
l'histoire
l'histoire montre ce qu'est la musique
les ont libérés un jeu remet d'un
dictateur qu'il est en sécurité et
éviter par l'état ira bien
il savait voyager là mais j'ai jamais
été invité par les permettra combat tout
à l'heure évidemment dans son couple qui
perdait que c'est que c'est que ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que l'on septembre
puisque on est vraiment très proche de
ces cérémonies là ce sera septembre
n'est pas un crime
au sens propre du mot c'est un châtiment
dire que les arabes ont voulu punir
l'amérique c'est pas un acte gratuit
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre il ya
tout un passé l'histoire n'a pas
commencé seulement le 11 septembre peut
pas justifier ce n'est pas jean ne peut
pas le terrorisme doit être juste il
expliqué moi ce que je voudrais et ça
c'est quand même à un de mes combats
depuis longtemps c'est qu'on arrête un
moment donné de pleurnicher de faire des
romans à l'intérieur de la tête de ceux
qui sont des victimes de davis des
vilains arables des méchants arabes qui
torturent et qui a faim qui cassa si
tout le monde et qu'on essaie de
comprendre pourquoi il y a il y à des
actes pareils je t'assure le désespoir a
poussé ddd des êtres humains à se
crasher sur des avions à temps avec des
avions dans des immeubles et ans et en
faire périr d'autres bien cette réponse
là elle existe dans la politique est
d'ailleurs ce qu'on fait croire on fait
croire que le que que les arabes sont
des islamistes par exemple que sont des
actes islamistes c'est pas parce que ben
laden est un religieux dans sa propre et
éthique de vie on va dire qu'il a fait
ses actes par religion
il ya fait ses actes comme réponse
politique c'est la politique occidentale
qui a poussé certains à rabat ce extrait
mise et c'est ça la vérité je ne pense
pas que le fait de sueur c'est les
arabes qui ont fait qu'ils ont commis
chez crimes du 11 septembre
ce ne sont pas les arabes ce sont
quelques arabes certains arabes
beaucoup d'arabes presque à penser par
exemple que ces religieux comme c'est
souvent 10 ou que ces politiques comme
le dit marc la loi religieuse du tout
c'est contre la religion islamique
complètement contre cet interdit parle
par la religion il ya beaucoup de
musulmans qui sont morts dans la dans
leurs 11 septembre dans la tour les
tours carotter donc ça ça n'a rien à
voir avec quelque chose dans mon roman
précédent qui s'appelait 99 francs
que j'ai écrit en 97 entre 97 et 99 a
donc avant le 11 septembre
je parlais énormément de l'hégémonie
américaine des multinationales de la
publicité et j'imaginais un acte
terroriste sur le sol américain
puisqu'il y avait un meurtre d'une
vieille dame en floride qui avait des
fonds de pension et qui était jugée
comme la responsable du malheur humain
et j'essayais de caricaturer déjà 7
cette façon un petit peu primaire de
montrer du doigt les américains comme
les responsables de nos malheurs
oui je crois c'est le tas tout un peu
simpliste et démagogique excusé mais que
j allais aussi dans ceux dans ton camp
si l'on peut dire puisque à un moment
donné tu fais tu poses la question tu te
demandes si c'est si les kamikazes ne
sont pas finalement des [ __ ]
fanatisés étudie et bien là et je fais
un oui un questionnaire à choix
multiples bien je trouve
ce oui non mais tu sais c'est dommage
d'éclat dommage qu'ils aient qui aimant
je ne savais pas stalinien c'est nouveau
chez toi oui alors au départ c'étaient
des amis si vous aussi vous voulez vous
jouez avec votre meilleure amie venait
sur ce plateau bien alors marc édouard
votre livre s'appelle printemps de feu
avec un bandeau naba bagdad c'est publié
aux éditions du rocher
dès les premières pages effectivement
vous affichez votre anti occidentalisme
par exemple vous êtes en syrie avant
d'aller à bagdad
et vous dites le pays qui fait trembler
les démocrates de mon hexagone honteux
si vous les gars l'unm qu une
humanisation terrible de ce qu'est
véritablement les ltte sont les
problèmes orientaux une fois qu'on les a
vaincus de l'intérieur il n'y a passé
que ce côté manichéen saisir dans la vie
il ya le bien le bien c'est à dire c'est
l'occident
l'occident avait malgré ses défauts la
démocratie la liberté malgré ses défauts
qui sont des grands mots derrière
lesquels finale alors à torture il ya
d'abord la nature mais ces masques c'est
que nos quelques la dureté sûr je veux
dire un exemple président actuel jean de
presse à moscou
on en irak du tout dire mais ça n'aurait
pas vécu ça ne suffit pas alors il y
aurait à son tour devenir un ventilateur
il ya plusieurs façons de tortue et
andré viola davis devant toi la
démocratie j'ai pas de filles la
démocratie la démocratie office a
d'autres à d'autres manières de torture
et les gens et de leur intime et le
silence et il faudrait quand même en
prendre conscience
même la liberté de ces que la mêlée
naturel à l'italienne par exemple qui
avait en irak était une caricature de
dictature était une était une dictature
tout à fait horrible et qui a duré 30
ans pendant un temps personne n'a rien
fait tout le monde aurait pu essayer de
l'arrêter saddam hussein
il a aidé tout le monde il a permis à
beaucoup de continent y compris les
américains et les européens de continuer
à s'engraisser à ceux à ceux à se gaver
de pétrole et à faire la guerre par
exemple l'eau d'iraniens etc
alors si on voulait vraiment arrêter un
dictateur il y en ad'autres plein
d'autres on n'avait qu'à le faire on
n'attendait pas qu'il en septembre qui
est un type comme george bush qui décide
par des raisons quasi freudienne ou
pathologique d'aller dégommer la gueule
d'un type comme saddam hussein parce
qu'il avait pas réussi à le faire avec
son propre père m'a haussement d'épaulés
s'impose même chez vous vous êtes vous
êtes à damas en syrie
quand les premières frappes sur bagdad
ont lieu vous cherchez un taxi pour
bagdad avec sherazade donc est une
danseuse que vous embarquer comme ça une
danse un formidable qui a eu le triste
qu'ils aient le courage des courageux me
suivre la bonne passe et avec elle le me
dites pas que c'est pas de la
provocation
quand vous arrivez à la douane irakienne
vous voyez des drapeaux palestiniens et
les drapeaux irakiens et vous dites
quelle émotion
oui parce que je pense que justement
c'est je trouve ça très émouvant qu'un
pays comme l'irak qui n'est pas
forcément concernés par le problème
palestinien parce que c'est très
nationaliste brême palestiniens et bien
aide symboliquement
les palestiniens dans leur combat je
trouve ça très bien saddam hussein c'est
pas moi qui vais défendre saddam hussein
jeu j'ai horreur des dictatures je suis
un anarchiste moi je suis obligé de
reconnaître que le que derrière le tyran
sanguinaire il ya 30 ans 40 ans
d'histoire et donc ça se fait pas comme
ça c'est pas juste une caricature on en
fait une sorte de l'opel vous voyez pire
ordi saddam hussein c'est un c'est un
gros porc un dégueulasse d'accord pour
ceux qui ont subi quand souffert de lui
ok mais il s'inscrit dans toute une
situation voilà alors quand vous arrivez
à bagdad je vais un peu vite quand vous
arrivez à bagdad s'est laissé les
journalistes vous dites ils sont filmés
fatigué devant des mosquées pour faire
couleur locale et on met un peu de fumée
pour faire effet guère les journalistes
rapport dans les six mois simplement
vous dire que par rapport aux
journalistes qui ont été tués là bas
c'est terrible oui ne sait pas les mêmes
l'alésien qu'une odeur ou cochon il n'a
été tué les juristes ont été exécutés un
par l'armée américaine pour les faire
taire il y à des mets des gens
d'ailleurs dont je parle des
journalistes qui sont très très
honorable qui ont fait très bien leur
métier c'est à dire ceux qui avaient le
plus de distance avec avec la situation
mais ce qui se baladait avec des vestes
safari avec les blés l'étude vous savez
les poches multi les peler le lave est
multipoches avec les crayons
le petit appareil photo et qui était
complètement encadrés par le basque il
faut savoir que y payer d'abord ce tous
les jours pour avoir le droit d'aller
voir des monuments détruits des
immeubles etc et il n'avait rien le
droit de dire et ils obéissaient aux
basses au garde à vous la passe qui
crient ils crient quand
intéressant
c'est intéressant mais c'est très fort
et donc toujours dans la même oreille je
suis un peu passionné ça lui vient ce
nom alors là vous êtes alors là ce même
de la provocation c'est à dire que vous
avez tort de souligner que mon livre
soit disant al ahly provocateur parce
que senna n'en attendait mark edwards
avec c'était un livre plutôt objectif
marquer c'est vrai que nos remarques et
la ranger votre marque et loire mayenne
trillard mais non non vous défendez le
port du voile
vous savez bien que ça va apparaitre ici
comme de la provo finalement d'être
finalement mutuellement laissez moi
parler vous dites que madame en orient
désormais pour un buisson là bas vous
vous dites me dit que pour un irakien
finalement montré le montrer le visage
de sa femme
c'est aussi obscène que montrer son
vagin et vous dites que le voile sert à
ce qu'on regarde d'abord les femmes
comme des êtres humains à vous avez une
théorique moyen de boue tout ça c'est
penser c'est que je veux dire bonjour
ici on est amis si on est on est dans
une dans un état et un continent où tout
est vu selon le le son problème moral et
sa propre pratique delà de la
civilisation
on croit que c'est ça la sexuation voilà
omar sharifi
garcia lille égyptien mais est ce que il
dit que finalement le port du voile
enfin lui comprendre très bien il dit
que c'est très bien parce que ça évite
quand on regarde les femmes comme des
objets sexuels que l'or ces chichis pas
envie de les débuter et clément le fait
de dévoiler ses de l'est c'est une forme
de respect s'est déconsidéré finalement
les êtres humains et non pas comme des
objets sexuels je suis contre si on
oblige une femme à porter le voile je
suis contre et si elle veut et qu'elle a
envie de porter le voile ou qu'elle a
envie de porter une écharpe pour qu'elle
a envie de porter un foulard ou qu'elle
a envie de porter un soutien gorge ou
pas ça la regarde mais voilà ça la
regarde je suis font l'effort
alors on continue pour rencontrer un
prêtre à bagdad
qui vous dit vous êtes un petit peu vous
finalement un catholique islamique et
vous dis tu oublies absolument je suis
un catholique islamique j'avais
tellement entendu c'est ce rapprochement
de mots comme ça et vous dites je suis
contre l' empire protestante finalement
vous sentez plus de 2 de proximité entre
les catholiques et musulmans monsieur je
suis pas un musulmane aux maniaques
mais je dois je suis obligé de
reconnaître et je ne suis pas le seul
que c'est dans l'islam qui a aujourd'hui
le plus de fois et que c'est le seul la
seule religion qui pourrait être
peut-être un jour en quand on leur a
purgée de ses excès je suis bien
d'accord
la seule région qui pourra être
révolutionnaire et révolutionnaire
contre quoi et bien contre l' empire du
fric lampions de la superficialité de la
mondanité delà de la frivolité de la
futilité
les ennuis n'avait résistants
d'aujourd'hui qui sont les résistants
d'aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas les
américains se sont pas les les lélés les
fils de bush se sont pas ceux qui
prônent à un an 1,1 occidentalisme
suffisant et arrogant j'ai résisté
aujourd'hui on le sait bien ce sont
seconds et ce sont aussi les musulmans
qui essayent de défendre leurs couleurs
terre où leur foi
d'accord je suis désolé mais je pense
que là c'est la volée monsieur savoir
une antenne de se battre pour la
frivolité pour la superficialité pour la
liberté
ça vaut la peine
un combat plus nomme lire dans la vie
que de se battre pour plus de
superficialité
je pense que la légèreté c'est une
valeur et je suis prêt à mourir pour
elle
je pense que cette espèce de puritanisme
dont tu te fais le héros soudain tout
d'un coup ça me concerne je suis contre
le puritanisme puritanisme c'est
l'oeuvre des protestants justement c'est
l'oeuvre de ce grand empire protestants
qui se met en route
voilà on peut pas trouver plus puritains
que aujourd'hui les protestants qui se
permettent d'aller d'aller dégommer la
gueule d'une civilisation qui a des
centaines et des centaines de modèles
noirs fois derrière eux une superbe on
dirait andré malraux je t'adore mais
simplement j'aurais quand même te dire
ce que j'ai fait ce que j'ai déjà dit au
début de l'émission
je crois qu'il faut pas être trop simple
c'est compliqué tous les américains ne
sont pas d'accord avec george bush
les américains sont un peuple
extrêmement critique les artistes
américains sont très subversif il ya
michael mauriac sean penn il ya
énormément de gens aux états unis qui ne
sont pas d'accord et que george bush ne
résume pas la milo l'assaut faire la
guerre et ses réserves est impardonnable
c'est sévère
on ne va pas mais il faut qu'on arrête
avec ce discours en disant au moins ils
ont fait chuter saddam hussein ne sert à
rien il est si la salle jean et non il
n'a pas été pris le bourbier continue et
je reviens il faut qu'on aille les aider
tu vas basile demain puis vertus et
valeurs demain jeudi
j'ai trop peur de rencontrer alors à ce
point du roman il faut voter à ce point
du roman marc-edouard découvre que la
danseuse du ventre shéhérazade et la
fille de saddam hussein 1 et vous
rencontrez saddam hussein qui vous
révèle d'ailleurs des choses qu'on ne
savait pas voilà sur le koweït et sur
ses deux jambes qu'il a fait tuer voilà
alors suis suis une éloge de la sodomie
hétérosexuels parce que cette pauvre
shérazade y passent donc là ça c'est pas
bien des papes au contraire j'adore le
personnage de sherazade elle est très
très lettré au contraire très bien servi
et alors au final donc pas la bataille
annoncée vous êtes très déçu parce que
vous y allez pour ça vous allez pour
pour vivre sous les sous les bombes
comme comme à dresde
on pourrait dire exactement et donc d'un
seul coup une victoire acheter puisque
oui vous dit que finalement on va vous
l'avez su après mais donc moi j'avais eu
des informations là bas que évidemment
donc le lit l'irak
enfin les américains commençaient à
arriver vers bagdad et voyant qu'il y
avait des ddd plus que des poches de
résistance à bassorah à nadjaf et bien
donc cette victoire allait être
impossible la bataille de bagdad allait
s'enliser pendant plusieurs semaines est
toujours très courageusement les
américains alors qu'on arrête de les
faire passer pour des super technicien
et des très grands combattants
ils sont allés apporter une mallette de
dollars à sofiane al tikriti et le
cousin de chef de la république et voilà
de saddam il a pris la mallette et il a
demandé à toute l'armée de ne pas
combattre
ils sont entrés en un quart d'heure
vingt minutes
je pense que marc edouard nabe a
toujours eu bien aimé se s'installer
dans des positions assez contradictoire
provocatrice et et scandaleuse par par
goût de je ne sais pas par certains un
certain messianisme masochiste un goût
du sacrifice et et voilà donc là il a
trouvé quelque chose de nouveau avant
c'était j'ai pas dire du mal des juifs
ou je sais pas quoi puis la ccsa donc
maintenant ben voilà c'est j'ai rien
d'autre rien à dire que c'est pour moi
c'est on sort de la littérature on sort
la littérature ce qui est important
c'est les phrases les mots le style peu
importe en effet c'est moche quand ils
me prennent mes rôles à aiguèze hirsch
avait l'oscar est pas moi je suis fou de
rage
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou